but the venom news continue Tom Hardy
teases spider-man in venom two buses
roll into this how's it going everybody
it's Warren welcome back to my channel
the cosmic wonder where we talk ever
Nicastro no reaction we finally got the
title and a tiny tiny little teaser from
a Sony for venom to officially titled
let there be carnage for those of you
wondering yes there is going to be
another teaser a better teaser where
they actually show footage but
unfortunately since the movie has been
pushed back so far that probably won't
come until at least another few months
but nonetheless you don't follow Tom
Hardy and it seems lawrence you
following Tom Hardy witness something
very well for the past week and a half
Tom Hardy has been teasing a spider-man
on his Instagram he's been posting
photos and then deleting them he's known
to do this and this time we have many
people who have proof this time now from
spider-man venom - let there be carnage
and Tom Hardy may be teasing that on his
Instagram so let's jump right in tonight
I'm doing a video announcing the
giveaway winner for five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so look out
for that so about a week ago before we
got the official venom two title and
teaser Tom Hardy posted a photo on his
Instagram and then deleted every ride on
this horror picture then I'm the biting
Slenderman basically cutting him in half
now this picture was very legitimate it
is confirmed that he did in fact post it
and then delete it and Tom Hardy has
been known to do this with other photos
and relations to venom - not many people
thought too much about it after all the
first photo that he posted had a caption
of just kidding however just yesterday
after the release of the venom 2 teaser
he posted it again and plenty of people
captured this one as well including
myself I physically saw it well for
starters he posted this immediately
after he posted the teaser for venom TV
here really so it seems to be
connected to venom - on the surface and
then we have the Morbius trailer Morbius
is going to be taking place in the same
universe that venom existent and we
already know that Morbius is kind of
going to tie it to the MCU he'll time to
the MCU but only in relations to
spider-man characters hence why we sell
vulture in the trailer so Morbius is
connected to venom but Morbius is also
connected to spider-man so it's safe to
assume that the venom verse that we have
going on right now with Sony is also
going to be connecting to the MCU
spider-verse as well and then you have
the fact that Sony actually wanted Tom
Holland to appear as spider-man in the
very first venom film however Marvel
said no they didn't want people to
confuse the Sony verse with the MCU but
after the whole spider-man and the MCU
Sony Disney Marvel Deal it looks like
Sony and Disney have struck up a new
arrangement and they've sort of created
their own little universe a universe
that doesn't exactly take place in the
MCU but the MJ spider-man so great it
seems like that just may be happening
because Tom Hardy has teased us now
twice now it may not mean anything but
there certainly is a president's for it
and we know that all of the fans are
dying to see venom and spider-man
together and Tom Hardy knows that as
well so for him to tease that Tom Halden
it was a pretty cruel joke but what do
what you think do you think Tom so he's
in the fact that spider-man could be
subscribe notifications turned on so you
could stay up to date on all things
relating to venom a to look out for my
giveaway video tonight and as always
thank you all so much for watching every
page of the Marvel I mean one way to
look at this is Tom Hardy could just be
messing with us knowing the kind of
personality has like yes he's a very
serious actor have you seen him in
enough interviews that dudes definitely
got a sense of humor and the fact that
you know serious actor it's kind of an
oxymoron when you think about it Johnny
Depp he said something like that I'm
kind of close not really anyhow it's
great
with Tom Hardy unsaid we willing to
immerse himself into these roles he kind
of gotta be willing to be someone who
takes the piss out of himself as well I
mean think about it if you're gonna like
stay in character on a movie set there's
a little bit of a goofy thing to it and
I can show that movies and I could see
Tom Hardy being the kind of guy who
loves to just mess with the fans
especially with the fact that he
uploaded it deleted it puts up this
venom to teaser uploads it and then
deletes it again unless there's some
publicist or Sony PR rep who's like what
are you doing teacher which was meant to
be Tom Hardy and Tom Holland just can't
stop putting it and Tom Holland has said
I remembered an interview way back when
where he did say he wants him to cross
over and I think bringing up Morbius in
this video is also a great thing to
include automatically it's venom so we
know he's tied into the spider-man
universe we already know that Morbius is
already gonna be linked in it even
closer based off of the trailer footage
with spider-man in the back what vulture
and appearing at the end of it we know
that they're at least attempting to do
it the one thing that we don't have is
confirmation of Tom Holland appearing in
it on the stance that I have especially
the fact that this is gonna be a carnage
villain LED film it's mean called let
there be carnage I just really want it
to be focused solely on that and if
anything and what I'm hoping they do is
that they have Tom Holland appear in
some fashion or some spider-man
mentioned in venom two that way we can
get spider-man and venom part 3 I mean
there's always rumors swirling of
sinister six and everything but I
wouldn't want him to appear at the end
of this one or the post-credits scene
instead he shows up right as venomous
save the day and he's like alright I'm
here well where's the other fights over
and then that's it and then he just
leaves and then you know then we can
hope that they'll team up next time or
maybe they'll get enough friends like
shaking you know he's confident about
what yeah sort of thing like is he gonna
just cut this right but it would be good
I mean John what do you think is he
trolling honestly I feel like this has
to be legitimate
in some way a because seems calculated
especially if Tom Hardy has a history of
putting out little images and then
deleting them I think he's probably
smart enough to know that that's a nice
way to play with people on social media
and he's probably also smart enough to
know that someone is good a screenshot
it and have it on hand and so to me this
reads as a fun way of viral marketing
because it seems like if Sony is smart
and I think they've learned some things
lately you know Tom Hardy is one of the
core engines that drives venom so yeah
if he wants to put some stuff out there
and keep people hyped and especially
right now keep people hyped I think a
that's just fun and B there's got to be
some kind of Spider Man presence in this
movie I don't know if it's Tom Hollands
spider-man or what because there are all
kinds of possibilities in Morbius it
looks like the Tobey suit and this one
it looks like the homecoming suit so
well it could just be some fan art yeah
whatever just alluding to the idea that
spider-man's gonna be in this one
there's gonna be some kind of fun
spider-man Easter Egg presence of some
variety coming our way for this if
anything we're more likely to get some
spider-verse tie him like an into the
spider verse one of those characters at
least a mention of that in the backdrop
or something yes spider bagel is more
likely to get a spider pig in there
there's a pagan here everyone's gonna
make a whole bunch of breakdown theories
carnage codes let's do a farm to kill
some guy there's a pig in the background
that black and white scene oh well
that's adorable spider-man or if some
black kid just appears as an extra in
the background every black character
could potentially be miles Tilley is
confirmed I mean if you look at like the
venom social media team they're having
fun they posted something on their
Twitter not long ago that was like
something weird that looked kind of like
a symbiote oh those worms the worms yeah
and they're like you wanted the venom
tracer so they were like messing with us
and I think Tom Hardy is probably in on
it and like the way the social media
teams of these comic book movies were
they know that if they put up anything
and if they're gonna take it down
they're gonna keep it up just long
enough for someone to screenshot oh yeah
they know people are gonna do that in
this time to keep
sizzle going the excitement the
anticipation cuz I think what we love as
moviegoers sometimes more than the
actual movie itself is the feeling of
looking forward to something so the
glimpses the main prize that's what
teases do that sir trailers do that's
what anticipation selling the sizzle not
the steak was really all about is having
people look forward to the future with
like him putting up and taking it down
that's a new version of teasing that we
might not have ever truly experienced
that is intentional oh yeah and we'll
give venom especially credit I think
that they've realized what worked well
about the first movie and obviously we
haven't seen the second one but I think
they're advertising and they're just
presence generally has a good amount
more life to it than a lot of other
franchises doing and I appreciate that
fun about it because it seems like
they're really playing into the fan
anticipation and having that back and
forth and the movie is appropriately
kind of cheeky enough for that I'm
excited for venom to moose at it for all
these news that keep coming now thanks
Warren I'm glad you finally hit 550
thousand subscribers after today we will
no longer react to you of course thanks
buddy
guys subscribe a cosmic wonder if you
haven't done so already I loved how you
work over emphasizing like ice creature
myself over people good live video yeah
going on here subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified whenever we got a YouTube
video what last but not least patron of
the day shadow I want to do one for
David Gandy today I talked with you
recently and I know you experienced a
very heavy loss which is not easy
ever I imagine especially during this
time though were forced to be an
isolation and Quarantine makes it even
harder and I know I've already sent you
a pretty lengthy message I wanted to be
here today to tell you that having you
in my life specifically has been an
absolute pleasure knowing just how
insanely kind you are and loving and how
you always do your best whatever it is
when it comes to doing kind deeds or
looking out
detecting being vigilant in those
qualities I can honestly say that the
person you lost knows that they were
truly loved by you I really love you I
really do man and you've been incredibly
special to us we have things you've sent
us before that we keep present visible
here look around it's more than just
like oh we got a cool gift like the
things you have done for us have been
very memorable you're part you're a part
of our life now yeah you know you're
such a thoughtful guy and you're such a
creative guy and I hope that you're able
at least now to kind of lean on those
things as well as your as your faith
kind of help bolster you during this
time and I know zoom meetings and Skype
meetings and facetiming are not
everything they're not as good as
interacting with your family and friends
and person but please do your best to
not be alone during this time and know
that you know even over here people who
don't live in the same city you do
you're looking out for you and I'll be
checking in with you as frequently as I
can I love you dude please be safe